so fox news which of course very loudly
and proudly
supports the police as they say uh is
refusing to run a one-minute ad
which features police officers
condemning the january 6th
trump riots consider the absurdity of
this
fox news has run endless opinion
programming
opposing the movements to reform police
and certainly to defund the police
they invite endless guests on to talk
about how we must support the police at
all costs and the police
are those who should be given leeway
all the time period because they are
protecting our communities and on and on
and on
and we should revere the positions and
opinions of police
and here we have capitol police officers
in a video criticizing republican
politicians who have repeatedly
attempted to downplay the seriousness of
the january 6
trump riots and they won't run the ad
check out the ad so that you know what
we're talking about this is an ad from
midas touch
i'm proud of the officers i worked with
on january 6th
they fought extremely hard our worst
nightmare really come true
an attack on american democracy right
here in the nation's capitol
i experienced the most brutal savage
hand-to-hand combat of my entire life
i received chemical burns to my face
that still have not healed to this day i
just remember
people still swinging metal poles at us
and they were pushing and shoving they
were spraying us
with uh you know bear mace and pepper
spray they were all shouting at us
calling us traitors
it's been very difficult seeing
elected officials and other individuals
whitewash the events that day or
downplay
what happened as an american and as an
army veteran
it's sad to see us attacked by our
fellow citizens
[Music]
midas touches responsible for the
content of this advertising yeah so
midas touch the company that produced
the ad
has said that the news outlet called
them last friday
to tell them that they weren't going to
be airing the ad
hold on a second though fox was
screaming back the blue
and all of this stuff all of last summer
during the george floyd
protests and then now we have a message
from police
and yet they don't want to run it don't
they support the police i guess they
don't support
these officers maybe they support like
the idea of the police maybe
and i'll actually get back to that in a
second the details of the ad buy
ben mizellis who's a co-founder of midas
touch
says they paid over 180 000 to have the
ad
over 184 thousand dollars to have the ad
run
from june 6 to 15th and that fox news
never actually explained to them or gave
them a reason why
they were not going to be running the ad
and
we know fox news's primary motivation is
money that's what's most
important to fox news so for them to
turn down
money for an ad that somebody is paying
them to air
you know they are doing it because it
would turn their narrative
on its head and be completely
devastating to them
as a channel is this a form of cancer
culture that they decry
they are cancelling the views of these
officers saying we will not allow them
on our channel
can we sign finally stop saying it was
ever really about blue lives matter and
about police and defending police
officers
it's time that we stop saying that it
was never about that
it's always been about opposing the
george floyd protests
whenever you bring up the blue lives
matter
uh movement in the context of the
january sixth riots which was trumpists
overrunning police injuring police
they never talk about it in that context
blue lives matter and support the police
is only talked about in the context of
george floyd or those types of incidents
but
when it's in the context of the january
6 riots where it was
trumpists overrunning officers it
becomes a non-issue then they don't want
to hear it
and so what is this really about what is
all of the support the police support
the troop stuff fundamentally about for
the right
it's not about police's individuals
that's
the distinction you have to understand
blue lives matter
is about supporting and defending police
as an institution as a center of power
same with soldiers and wars with the
support
from the republican party of the iraq
war in 2003
think back to that support the troops
didn't mean
support individual soldiers and make
decisions that will keep them safe and
out of harm's way
if you care about the individual soldier
you don't send them into harm's way to
begin with
for such a hare-brained war meant to
retaliate against 911 which wasn't even
done by iraq
you don't do that if you care about the
individual soldiers so support the
troops meant
i basically support republican president
george w bush
doing whatever the hell he wants uh as
far as
uh troops and the military are concerned
and it is basically more of the same
with the police stuff
support the police might apply to
individual officers
maybe for example if an officer has been
charged in the killing
of another unarmed uh civilian then it's
oh
support the police means support the
individual officers but now all of a
sudden hey we've got a group of officers
they have something to say
these were people that were there front
and center on january 6 at the trump
writes
they have a message for us here's money
fox just play the message oh no no no
no support the police means something
very very different then let
these officers get their point across
and
there's no question about the legality
of what fox news did fox news has every
right
to accept or turn down any particular
advertiser there's no question
whatsoever
but let's not fall for this bogus back
the blue
support the police stuff that they claim
because they abandon it like that
as soon as it's inconvenient to their
narrative
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
a subscription streaming service that
offers
thousands of documentaries from some of
the world's best filmmakers
including titles you can't find anywhere
else if you are
serious about watching documentaries and
you don't have curiosity stream
i don't even know what you're doing my
girlfriend and i
have not been able to get enough
curiosity stream
we can watch it on the tv smartphone
ipad
all of the devices they have
documentaries on politics history
science economics technology i recently
watched berlin 1945.
super interesting uh hopefully in
advance of being able to actually visit
berlin as things open up
a really excellent film curiosity stream
is always adding new titles i have
definitely noticed a lot of great stuff
on curiosity stream that's not available
on netflix hulu or
amazon when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman you will get unlimited access to
the world's top documentaries and for my
viewers
because you're so great when you use the
promo code pacman
you'll get 25 off a subscription making
it only
14.99 a year